graph coloring is the abstract version
of a problem that arises from a bunch of
conflict scheduling situations so let's
look at an example first and then define
the problem so let's think about a bunch
of aircraft that have to be scheduled on
the ground a Czech ports or gates now if
two flights are on the ground at the
same time they need to be assigned to
different gates since again serves one
airplane and what we'd like to do is try
to figure out how many different gates
do we need to be able to service all the
planes that might be on the ground how
many gates are needed so let's look at a
sample schedule there are six flights
here numbering 120 to 145 through 99 and
these the horizontal bar is say times
during the day and this blue block
indicates that flight 122 is on the
ground from let's say 3 a.m. to 7 a.m.
and fight 145 is on the ground and a
completely different disjoint time
interval so 67 to 57 is on the ground
from midnight until about 6 a.m. it does
overlap with 122 and so on so this is
the information we have and what we're
trying to figure out is how many gates
do we need well it's easy to see here
that the worst case if you just think of
this a vertical Green Line sliding
across the bar and you look at the
maximum number of blue intervals that
the Green Line ever crosses it's 3 the
largest number of planes that are on the
gate at any given moment is 3 which
means we can get by with 3 gates so we
have to cope with that conflict now so
abstractly what we're going to do is
assign each aircraft to be a vertex of a
graph and we're going to put an edge in
to indicate not compatibility but
conflict compatibility was what we were
looking at previously with our examples
of matching now this line means that 306
and 145 are on the ground at the same
time they conflict they need the same
gate and we have to serve them with
different gates and likewise 99 and 145
are on the ground
$6.99 this was that that the three
flights that were on the ground at the
same time and then if I fill in the
computer graph with all the other
vertices and draw an edge when two
flights are on the ground at the same
time I wind up with this little graph
okay
now we can talk abstractly about the
coloring problem which is let's assign
colors to the vertices in such a way
that no two adjacent vertices have the
same color okay adjacent vertices should
have different colors and it should be
clear from the description of how we
derive this graph from the airline
aircraft schedules that the minimum
number of distinct colors needed to
color the graph corresponds to the
minimum number of gates needed to serve
the aircraft so let's try coloring this
graph I'll start with coloring for 257
red and 122 yellow and 99 green there's
no loss of generality here because these
are the three that are on the ground at
the same time reflected by the fact that
they're in a triangle and I'm gonna have
to use three different colors since each
one is adjacent to the other two okay
what next well let's color 145 yellow I
might as well reuse it since it's not
adjacent to a yellow vertex and then um
here I've got a another triangle so if
I'm not going to use an extra color the
sensible thing to do would be to color
that red but opus I didn't do that I use
the red here there's another triangle I
guess that's that allows me to color and
then I color this black because here I'm
stuck I'm adjacent to both a yellow a
black and a green vertex so I have to
come up with a fourth color all right we
did with four colors it means that we
could could have gotten away with four
gates and the colors tell us which
aircraft to assign to which gate so 257
and 67 can both be assigned to the red
gate because they are not on the ground
at the same time there's no edge between
them 122 and 145 can be assigned a
yellow gate and so on now this was not
the smartest way to color a better
coloring you're shown here you can check
that every two adjacent vertices have
different colors and now I've done it
with only three colors red
yellow and green so now there are three
gates and I get a better schedule
another example of this kind of conflict
problem comes up with scheduling final
exams two subjects conflict if a student
is taking both because if a student is
taking both I can't have the final exams
at the same time and so I need to assign
different timeslots during exam period
two subjects that overlap that have a
student in common and then the question
is given this data about which pairs of
subjects have a student in common we
want to know how short an exam period
can we get away with again it becomes a
simple graph model and a coloring
problem so here we've drawn a graph with
some sample subjects 604 2 and 1802 have
a student in common that's what that
edge means they need to be have final
exam scheduled at different times
likewise 802 and 604 to have a student
in common so they need to be scheduled
at different times on the other hand 604
2 and 1802 sorry what are some two that
are not adjacent
309 1 and 1802 have no edge between them
which means that they can be scheduled
at the same time there's no student
who's taking both 309 1 and 1802 at
least according to the data in this
graph so let's try covering it and again
it is a triangle I'm gonna have to use
three different colors for a triangle
and here's another triangle and to be
economical let's just reuse green now
here I've got another vertex that's
adjacent to three different color
vertices and so it's gonna have to be
colored with a fourth color this time it
turns out that the four colors are best
possible you can check that and it
corresponds to a schedule in which the
604 2 is scheduled on Monday morning at
nine and six double-o one is scheduled
on Monday at 1:00
but 802 and 309 one can both be
scheduled for Tuesday 9:00 a.m. and
finally 1802 is scheduled on Tuesday at
1:00 p.m.
okay so this kind of a conflict modeling
situation comes up all the time
another place where you get these kind
of compatibility graphs or
incompatibility graphs that you want to
color would be if you were running a zoo
and you had to have separate habit
habitats for certain kinds of species of
animals that you don't want to mix
together big fish eat little fish it's a
truism in the aquarium world and so you
need to keep big fish separate from
little fish and you don't want the
Tigers living together with the
chimpanzees so we could again model this
problem as how many cages do we need we
create a vertex for each species and put
an arrow between an edge between two
species that mustn't share a habitat or
spheric or share a cage another one
would be assigning different frequencies
to radio stations and again if two radio
stations are close to each other they
they will interfere and so they have to
be assigned to different colors or
different frequencies so now we would be
using radio stations as vertices and
radio stations that were near enough to
interfere with each other would get
connected by an edge indicating that
they needed to be assigned different
color frequencies and one of the classic
ones is literally to color a map if you
were trying to take say a map of the US
and assign colors to it in such a way
that you never had two states that
shared a border with the same color and
this is an illustration of doing it with
four colors the question is if I give
you some kind of a planar map like this
what's the minimum number of colors that
will work now you're allowed to have two
vertices with the two countries rather
share the color if they only share a
meet at one point but if they have a
positive length boundary they have to be
different colors okay the way that this
turns into a vertex coloring problem is
if you take a planar graph like this
here's just an arbitrary one what I can
do is I'm interested in coloring the
regions the
tres with different colors but I'll just
replace each region by a vertex so I'm
going to stick a vertex in the middle of
each of the regions notice there's an
outer region here - that gets a vertex
so one two three four five six regions
four six vertices and then I'll simply
connect two vertices when there is a
positive length edge that their regions
share so there's that vertex that edge
corresponds to the fact that there's
this boundary that's shared between this
region in this region if you look at
this same triangular shaped region it
has a boundary with the outside region
so there's going to be an edge from here
to the vertex that represents the
outside and there's the rest of the
edges and edge appears when between two
regions that share a boundary and now
the question is coloring the countries
corresponds to coloring the vertices and
we'd like to color the graph with as few
colors as possible well a famous result
that was proved in the seventies is that
every planar graph is in fact four
colorable now this was first proved to
claim to be proved in the 1850s but in
fact the published proof was wrong its
sat around in the journal literature for
a decade before somebody found a bug or
that is to say that the proof was wrong
not the result there was a big hole in
the proof that that had not been
adequately justified the proof did give
a correct argument for five coloring and
the four color problem was opened for
over a hundred years then in the 1970s
two mathematicians came up with a proof
of the four color theorem that was very
controversial because a lot of it of
their proof required a computer program
to crank through several thousand sample
graphs that needed to be verified for 4
colorability they had an argument that
showed that that there could only be a
few thousand counter examples if there
was or rather if there was any graph
that couldn't be for colored it would be
one of these several thousand graphs and
then they went to work on coloring these
several thousand graphs which were
generated with the age eight of a
computer and then colored with the aid
of a computer and also by hand
this did not make the mathematical
community happy because a proof like
that is essentially uncheck Abel a much
improved version was developed in the
1990s but it still requires in the end a
computer program to generate about 600
maps and verify their caller ability so
it remains to find a proof of the
four-color theorem that you could say is
humanly comprehensible without the aid
of a computer but there's no longer any
doubt really about this theorem in the
mathematical community in general if I
take an arbitrary graph and I ask what's
the minimum number of colors to color it
that's called the chromatic number of
the graph so Chi of G is the minimum
number of colors to color G and let's
look at some guys for different kinds of
graphs so here we have a simple cycle of
length four and it's obvious that that
can be colored with two colors just
alternate the colors on the other hand
so what and if that generalizes I by the
way to any even length cycle the the
chromatic number of an even length cycle
is simply two you will color the
vertices alternately on the other hand
if the cycle is of odd lengths you're
gonna need a third color there's no way
around it because even if you try to get
by with two colors then your color
things alternately and then when you
wrap around you discover that um you
can't alternately color you're going to
need a third color in order to avoid a
clash so in general the chromatic number
of an odd length cycle is three the
complete graph on five vertices is shown
here this is a five vertex graph in
which every vertex is adjacent to the
other four and since every vertex is
adjacent to the other four you're going
to need five colors you can't do any
better they have to all have different
colors and so the chromatic number of
the complete graph on n vertices where
every vertex is adjacent to the other n
minus one is n another simple example
that comes up is if I take the cycle and
I put a an axe
and Axel in the middle call it a wheel
then a wheel with a a ring of light a
cycle of length five around the outside
a perimeter of length five is called W
five and we can color it with four
colors and in general the argument for
that the chromatic number for an odd
length wheel is four is that I know I'm
going to need three colors to color the
rim and since the axle is adjacent to
everything on the rim I'm going to need
a fourth color for it on the other hand
again if the if the perimeter is even
though I can get by with three colors
one more remark about chromatic numbers
is there's an easy argument that shows
that if you have a graph every one of
whose vertices is at most degree K there
are at most K other vertices adjacent to
any given vertex then that implies that
the graph is K plus one colorable and
the proof is really constructive and
trivial basically you just start
coloring the vertices any way you like a
subject to the constraint that when you
color a vertex it's supposed to not be
the same color as any of the vertices
around it but that's easy to do because
when it's time to color some vertex even
if all the vertices around it are
coloured there's only K of them and so I
will always be able to find a k plus
first color to assign it without and get
a satisfactory coloring so I can get by
with K plus 1 colors now the general
setup with color ability is that to
check whether a graph is 2 colorable is
actually very easy and we may talk about
that in some class problems but 3
colorability dramatically changes we're
back in the realm of np-complete
problems in fact a result of a student
of mine almost 40 years ago was that
even if a graph is planar where you know
it can definitely be colored with four
colors determining whether or not it can
be colored with three colors is as hard
as satisfiability
and it is in fact an np-complete problem
in fact the proof of how you reduce
satisfiability the color ability appears
in a problem in the text which we may
assign as a problem set problem
so in general finding Chi of G is hard
even for three colors now it's not any
worse again from a theoretical point of
view for for checking what Khayyam G is
even if it's a very large number or the
pragmatically three color will be easier
to check than end color ability and that
is our story about color ability